[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
I'm sure by now even before this video
you have seen Marvel Studios is big game
TV spot that they aired during the Super
Bowl a couple of days ago this TV spot
trailer of course gave us our first
looks at the Falcon in the Winter
Soldier series of the 1 division series
and a brief little preview of the Loki
series as well 3 out of the 5 Disney
Plus shows that are going to be coming
to Marvel Studios as phase 4 yesterday I
broke down everything that you needed to
know about the Wanda vision series and
if you didn't catch that you can check
it out in the link up above and today in
this video I'll be breaking down the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier trailer
that we got and the brief little preview
that we got of the Loki series if you're
new be sure to subscribe to stay up to
date on everything happening in the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 and
I'll talk more about the giveaway at the
end of the video okay so the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier TV spot trailer
starts off with Falcon throwing Captain
America shield into a tree now notice
the form he's throwing it just like
Steve Rogers obviously at the end of
Avengers in game we left off with Steve
Rogers passing down the mantle and the
shield to Sam Wilson aka Falcon making
Falcon the new Captain America or so we
thought more on that in a bit but
clearly in this shot he's been
practicing being at Captain America but
where exactly is Sam right now he's not
in a place that we've seen before at
least not to anybody's knowledge yet but
it does seem like he's moved away from
New York where the Avengers compound was
and moved down south the reason that
everybody thinks this is because of the
environment where he's at the trees and
the lakes specifically these specific
trees are found in southern states which
leads us to believe that he is somewhere
down south but why did Sam who was
supposed to be the new Captain America
leave the Avengers well despite the fact
that Sam helped save the universe and
Avengers in game before Avengers
infinity war after the events of civil
war he was a wanted man and we know that
for whatever reason it may be the
government does not want Sam to be the
next Captain America most likely because
the government feels that he betrayed
them when he went with Captain America
to save Bucky so the government doesn't
let Sam be the new Captain America
despite the fact that Steve Rogers the
former Captain America passed the mantle
down to him so Sam leaves now whether
that's out of anger or whether that's
because he wants to go into hiding who
knows but he won't be alone for
we quickly get into some awesome aerial
action scenes we see Falcon soaring
through the sky with his wings of course
chasing some people who are in wingsuits
now this could take place in the past as
we know that the Falcon in the Winter
Soldier are going to explore just a tiny
bit into the past of Falcon but if we
look closely it's been pointed out that
one of the persons in this wingsuit that
turns around to shoot at Falcon looks an
awful lot like Zemo we've known that
Zemo is going to be returning for the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier series for
some time now his role really hasn't
been revealed yet but of course
everybody is expecting that he's going
to be the main villain and that Sam and
Bucky are going to have to track him
down but it looks like they do so pretty
easily at least Bucky did the next scene
we have is of Bucky and Zemo Bucky is
holding a gun to zimas head but in
another scene which appears to be a part
of the same scene we see somebody
dropping bullets and this does appear to
be Bucky's hand if you notice when he's
holding the gun he's holding it with his
right hand and the bullets that are
being dropped are being dropped out of
the left hand now you notice that the
hand looks black almost like somebody's
wearing a glove but this is most likely
Bucky's new vibranium arm which is black
and if this is the case that means that
Bucky does in fact track down Zemo and
finds him but doesn't kill him instead
it kind of seems like he forgives him
but why would that happen and how did
Baron Zemo actually get out of prison
well there actually are a few pretty
simple explanations for how this could
have happened
one is that he could have escaped during
or after the snap or now as everybody is
calling it the blip he could have been
in prison and some prison guards could
have been blipped out of existence which
could have led him to escape somehow if
he managed to get some keys or managed
to find a way to open up the door or he
could have possibly been blipped himself
now in spider-man far from home they
showed us that the people who got
blipped out of existence were snapped
right back to the exact same spot when
they were snapped in the first place
which means Zemo could have been snapped
out of existence the guards could have
noticed that he was missing and his cell
could have been open when he got snapped
back now although I think that these are
very possible what I truly think is
going on here and how I truly think
Baron Zemo got out of prison is I think
that Thunderbolt Ross let him out I
think that Zemo is going to be one of
the first persons recruited for the Thun
bolts a few insiders in the community
have said that they can confirm that the
thunderbolts are indeed coming and
they're most likely going to be
Thunderball Ross's Thunderbolts and Russ
does have the power to let Zemo out of
jail and pardon him for anything that he
may have done so Marvel may be making
Zemo out to be the main villain of the
show but perhaps there's more that we
don't know
because if I had to guess it's probably
Thunderbolt Ross who was the one who
said Sam can't be the new Captain
America if so it seems like Ross has a
master plan that will see unveiled in
phase four and then to top the trailer
off we get our very first look at the
new Captain America now I've noticed
that some people are actually kind of
confused about this I hear people are
asking the question is this Bucky or is
this Falcon well it's actually neither
it's US agent John Walker now this is
going to be a government-appointed
Captain America as it was in the comics
when they introduced us agent and it's
actually a pretty similar story to
what's going to happen in the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier Steve Rogers is no
longer Captain America but of course
America needs a new Captain America Sam
was supposed to be the new Captain
America but the government decided that
it wasn't time so instead they chose us
agent John Walker and in this footage we
can see a welcoming for him a sort of
celebration for the new Captain America
the band is playing there are fireworks
shooting off in the background and
everybody is cheering for him he has a
new suit of course it can't be like the
last Captain America Steve Rogers and if
you notice he has a new Captain America
logo and of course he has the Captain
America shield but if you notice it
doesn't show the front of the shield
therefore we can't tell if this is the
same shield that Captain America Steve
Rogers gave to Sam Wilson or if it's a
completely new shield made by vibranium
or another very strong metal or if it's
perhaps a prop because you have to
remember that when Captain America first
came around he was kind of used as a
publicity stunt by the government he was
used to get people cheering and to get
their hopes up in a time of war when
things were pretty bad and it seems like
they're kind of doing the same thing
with our new Captain America US agent
John Walker by holding this big
celebration for him and the new Falcon
and Winter Soldier footage ends with
Bucky and Falcon shaking hands in front
of wherever Falcon is currently at this
is most likely where the two of them
reunite for the very first time
and then we move on to a very brief clip
of Loki I'm gonna burn this place to the
ground
now although this is pretty short it
actually has a major easter egg and
detail that you may have missed you may
notice that he's in somewhat of a
prison-like uniform and on this uniform
are the letters T V a now you may think
that's nothing but T V a actually stands
for the time variance Authority and is
actually quite a big reveal about what's
happening with Loki the time variance
Authority are a timeline agency the time
variance Authority was introduced in
Thor number 372 in 1986 they're an
interdimensional agency whose main
purpose is to maintain the boundaries
between alternate realities if somebody
in a time line or perhaps the entire
timeline itself becomes too dangerous to
the surrounding timelines the time
variance Authority will step in and
attempt to eliminate the threat or
eliminate the entire timeline in order
to protect the surrounding timelines
they also attempt to stop people from
altering the past or future events to
their own benefit which we know 100% is
confirmed that Loki is going to do one
of the synopses for the Loki series says
that he will travel throughout time and
impact major historical events and that
is exactly what the TIV is designed to
stop and as we can see from this footage
they've done their job Loki is in their
custody now this does confirm that Loki
has in fact been traveling through time
affecting major events and he's not just
travelling in his own timeline he's
travelling in alternate timelines as
well so gallivanting throughout time
doing whatever you once would definitely
put him on the T a V's radar and most of
the timelines that involved the Avengers
did get cleared up when Captain America
returned all of the Infinity stones
however of course there were still some
loose ends
Loki being one of them so Loki was most
likely the only if not one of the only
major threats to the T a V and other
alternate realities now it is worth
noting that in the comics the TIV isn't
particularly good at their job in fact
they fail to stop a nihilist and Kang
the Conqueror in the comics and they
actually have to call on help from the
Avengers quite often but somehow they
managed to capture Loki unless Loki
wanted to be caught let's go back to the
very first Avengers film where Nick Fury
captures Loki but
very quickly points out that he feels
like loki is the only one that actually
wants to be on the ship which was true
loki intentionally got caught which
leads me to believe that now he
intentionally got caught by the t AV
they were probably following him around
for some time and knowing loki it was
probably pretty annoying to him
and we hear him say in the trailer i'm
going to burn this place to the ground
and he says that with that classic loki
mischievous smile and that smile
definitely looks like he's saying this
was my plan get captured so you could
bring me to your base and so i could
escape and burn it down but who knows
perhaps they're competent in the MCU and
actually did manage to capture loki but
let me know what you think about the
first looks that we got at the falcon in
the Winter Soldier series and the Loki
series as well be sure to let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and don't forget to like the video and
subscribe when notifications turned on
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 the winner gets to choose
and I'm picking a winner at five hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers don't
forget to follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof